what type of weather do zombies most
like Cloudy with a Chance of brain hey
guys I'm Brent Rose writer and sci-fi
Seinfeld so we're living in the age of
digital assistance Apple's got Siri
Google's got assistant
Microsoft has Cortana and Amazon has
Alexa not now
so if you've ever been bored you've
probably started messing with your
digital assistant to see what kind of
funny responses you can get all of these
devices are chock full of jokes so bad
that make your dad look like Dave
Chappelle but one of them's got to be
the funniest so we've devised the test
we're going to assemble a stand-up
comedy routine composed entirely of
jokes from these four devices and then
I'm gonna take it to a stand-up comedy
club here in LA and perform it in front
of a live audience it's gonna suck a lot
all right
so I've assembled my digital writers
room here let's do this thing
Siri tell me a joke I used to know this
one tell me another joke I can't
I always forget the punchline okay so as
far as jokes go Siri is absolutely
terrible but she's more trained to have
funny responses to questions you asked
her for example Siri what's your
favorite animal I don't really have one
on this planet huh huh so Apple didn't
do too well there let's see if Microsoft
has an answer Cortana is Microsoft's
digital assistant it's available on
Windows Phone Xbox Windows 10 and now as
a standalone app for Android and iPhones
Cortana tell me a joke why do scuba
divers always fall backwards out of the
boat if they fell forwards they'd still
be in the boat this is already better
than Apple's I mean it's not good but
it's better than Apple tell me a joke
there are two types of people in the
world those who need closure I like this
so let's give Google Assistant a try
assistant is in the new Android devices
and it's also in the Google home system
and possibly coming to Chrome sometime
soon - okay Google
tell me a joke as a golfer it's always
smart to wear two pairs of pants you
know in case you get a hole-in-one
tell me another one why do fish live in
saltwater because pepper water makes
them sneeze
and lastly this is Alexa this is
Amazon's Amazon's assistant it's in the
echo products and coming to more things
soon Alexa tell me a joke
what do lemons drink when they get sick
a lemonade want to hear a dirty joke a
boy fell in some mud how about a clean
joke he had a shower neither of those
are jokes ok let's get a few more and
then hit the club
what do clouds wear under their shorts
Thunder pants what do you call an empty
jar of keys with one chocolate chunk as
much as the woodchuck could chuck of the
woodchuck ok so we've got the best jokes
these things have to offer and oh my god
this is gonna be so brutal ok so we're
at the Chatterbox and I am about to do
stand-up comedy for the first time in my
life this is my stand-up comedy uniform
plaid on the car ride over I literally
cut and copied and pasted all of the
best jokes from our four devices we've
got about seven for each we're listening
to laughs duration laughs intensity we
have a decibel meter so hopefully we'll
get some real data here this is a pretty
widely known open mic night for stand-up
comedians and I do not belong here so I
so tell me tell me a little bit about
this place is the Chatterbox the open
mic this thing right here that you're is
one of the best open mics in LA have you
done stand-up before no never I've
always been afraid of bombing and I feel
like I'm guaranteed to Bob do you know
what that feels like
tamam no it's worse than any physical
pain and I'm not kidding when I tell you
that
that did not make me feel any better at
all I'm afraid of this getting straight
food up the stage he's got a gong back
there I stayed up all night trying to
figure out where the Sun went and then
it dawned on me why do the scuba divers
always fall backwards out of the boat
that's because if they fell forwards
they'd still be in the boat a ham
sandwich walks into a bar bartender says
sorry we don't serve food here huh good
good so we have to address the elephant
in the room here these artificial
intelligence assistants are not writing
these jokes themselves these are all
canned responses computer scientists are
very much working on AI that can come up
with jokes and some even believe it'll
be the final stage in making a truly
lifelike AI what steps are these
companies taking to try to make these
devices funnier Google hired writers
from Pixar and the onion to try to make
assistant more lifelike
in 2013 Apple posted a job listing
looking for writers for Siri Microsoft
hired screenwriters journalists and even
a poet to give Cortana a human touch and
in addition to having a bunch of curated
jokes with Alexa you can install whole
libraries of dad jokes dirty jokes even
jokes directly from reddit for this test
was one of the even playing fields we've
got all four devices performing as they
would right out of the box I told the
doctor I broke my arm in two places he
told me don't go into those places do
you think frogs are any good at surfing
totally what did the puppy want to be
when he grew up AB archaeologist
[Laughter]
what did one iphone say to the other
iPhone I used to know this one which
horse runs the city the mayor of course
what's the best part of living in
Switzerland I don't know but the flag is
a big plus which baseball player has the
shortest commute the catcher he only
works from home the electron asked the
photon do you pet did you pack your
suitcase the photon responded no I'm
travelling light the nerd gets it what
do you do when you see a spaceman you
park in it man how did the hipster burn
his lips he drank his coffee before it
was cool what's the difference between a
hippo and a Zippo well one is very heavy
the other is a little lighter why did
the chicken cross the road
roll in the mud and cross the road again
because he was a dirty double-crosser
[Laughter]
that was that was rough we expected to
be rough and it was rough it was like
every time a joke died I felt like I was
dying a little bit inside at least it
validated our general feeling that none
of these devices are very funny and the
audience agreed anyway let's get to the
results Siri was absolutely hands-down
the least funny of these four AI
assistants
she doesn't even really try serious up
next was Amazon's Alexa which had a
couple good jokes and you can add skills
but out of the box it's just kind of
cheeseball stuff that was really really
cringe-worthy
so that leaves first and second to
Google's assistant Microsoft's Cortana
and it was actually really close between
these two they were just a little bit
more clever and they got a little bit
more of a laugh out of the audience
neither of them should ever be actual
stand-up comedians but for the purposes
our tests they fared the best but what
do you think let us know in the comments
below subscribe to wire it if you
haven't already with all that being said
there's really only one thing left to do
so as may be obvious I'm not a stand-up
comedian at all I'm actually a
journalist from Wired and we asked Siri
and Google's assistant and Amazon Alexa
and Microsoft's Cortana to tell us the
very best jokes that they could we
wanted to come here and see which ones
would do the best so you guys have
really been very very helpful for this
extremely brutal experience for me
thank you guys goodnight
[Applause]
[Music]